i'm most excited for this one hell yeah
man like where's the ice so grizzled and
where is he standing right now he's in
some nice sunny warehouse and he's just
they're like hey nick
i don't want to look at the sun
even though i don't got my eye patch in
and that would be really convenient
right now and that is the question
where's that eye patch maybe he's like
who took my ipad first they take my
shoes then they take my ipads like this
where's goose he took my
[Laughter]
i'm the best goose you're ever gonna get
i'm trying not to do accents of these
actors because it just doesn't sound
right when i try to do accents so i'm
just saying the text as is that's the
proper way i should do it i think let's
hear your chris tucker eric
no thank you
[Laughter]
please don't ever touch my radio
amazing it's like he's here with us it's
awesome authentic welcome back to new
rockstars marvel's secret invasion is
coming with reports of production taking
place in leeds in the uk in the past
week meaning this may actually be a
title we see on disney plus by the end
of 2022 who is amelia clark playing on
this series how many mcu characters will
cross over into it and who is secretly a
skrull
what the flirt
this is inside marvel it's our weekly
marvel reaction show i'm eric boss i'm
back this week with mt hello mt what's
going on buddy um question are you a
scroll my friend i have to ask i have to
just ask generally everybody
i'm never gonna reveal the answer to
that question because even if i said i
was i'd be like i'm not the werewolf i'm
not
saying look at him he's the freaking
scroll so all i all i'll say is i did
not get a call from
i didn't get a call from taylor's okay
that's all i'm saying
i didn't get a call
if i look and sound different to the
viewers right now it's because um
where i'm actually in a new instead set
up i moved this past weekend so i have a
a new room that i'm trying to set up a
new camera that i'm looking through
while i set up a prompter so um forgive
me if i just sound a little awkward or
if i'm looking down uh every now and
then uh it doesn't mean i love you any
less it just means that um
i'm technically incapable
and i'm technically incapable of doing a
lot of things but we won't get it that's
not true you lie you lie
there's a certain level of intimacy you
and i have not yet reached so you can't
really speak from experience there this
is true soon
i don't know what that means i'm sorry
that's really creepy my fingers are too
long as far as i know this guy doesn't
need any blue chew that's what it means
he doesn't know
we're already off the rails in this
episode these scroll search is back on
ladies and gentlemen as new information
is starting to come out about marvel's
secret invasion we're going to break
down everything about this upcoming
series but first a little uh
announcement we want to remind you guys
about new rock stars uh folks friends uh
followers people vaguely interested in
us that might live in the chicagoland
area you will be able to see
me and jessica clements and tommy
bechtold and philip molina live in
person on february 11th i believe at 8
p.m new rockstars is doing a live show
with our friends at rooster teeth in the
face jam podcast at talia hall in
chicago as part of the very normal
podcast store
and it's going to be a really really fun
show
we're going to be real silly we're going
to be doing something different things
that you don't normally see on the
channel we're gonna talk about live in
person uh and uh yeah it'll be just nice
to to see
anybody who shows up just to meet you
potentially uh so click the link in the
video's description or check our new
rockstars social media accounts for the
ticket info there uh but empty what is
our question in this episode of inside
marvel well eric what the flirkin are
the latest new details about marvel's
secret invasion
yes well just a quick reminder to uh our
viewers who may not be currently up to
date on marvel's secret invasion it's uh
one of the big marvel crossover events
in the comics it was around 2008 2009 in
which it is revealed that alien
shapeshifters the squirrels were have uh
have infiltrated the ranks of all of
earth's institutions including the
avengers and it leads all of us to ask
the question
who
do you trust
don't trust anyone not even your mom
don't trust the uh the poor grammar of
this question because it should be whom
not who but that's okay you trust
who miss grimora
brian needs me as an object uh well i
gotta say when they announced that uh
they were gonna do this as a mini series
i was a bit surprised because it's such
a big event uh it's it's up there you
know with civil war i would say it comes
shortly after civil war but at the end
of the day i think this is the best way
to do it in fact i think um
more of these marvel titles should be
six episode miniseries it gives us more
time to spend with all the characters to
to tease the mysteries to let the reveal
surprise us to like spend two months
talking about it i honestly think like
eternals would have benefited from oh
dude absolutely you i would love to
spend six episodes with all those guys
because that was such a huge ensemble of
europe yeah the more characters you have
the more stacked your your cast is the
more you want to spend time with him
right
so in terms of the production process on
this show we saw this teaser early
november right during marvel's disney
plus day uh but just that shot of nick
fury was the only official thing
released other than the title card
they've been shooting in the uk in the
past few months they shot in london in
september and october and a production
for secret invasion has resumed in the
uk in recent days in the city of leeds
where
you could see
nick fury and amelia clark being spotted
around the city and then next week uh
production is expected to move on to
halifax at peace hall now um i should
say there's nothing particularly
groundbreaking about the new footage but
we do see fury has a bearded grizzled
look and no eye patch i'm just super
pumped empty to see this series moving
forward just to potentially see a
trailer in the next couple months
hopefully a late 2022 release date now
amelia clark is a an interesting casting
choice for this series because she joins
an all-star cast that also includes
kingsley benadir who's going to be
playing a lead villain of the show
olivia coleman
in some unknown role and of course our
friends samuel l jackson could be
smaller since maria hill ben mendelson
returning his talos and this far i think
this is the most stacked cast we have
ever seen on a marvel disney plus series
am i wrong um just by having sam jackson
alone um that's pretty stacked um
sam jackson alone in that weird
warehouse staring at the wall here
i would watch six episodes of that
he's like do you mind
he's like why are you looking at me do
you mind he looks annoyed that we're
like we're watching him he's like i
guess man
why doesn't he just start streaming on
youtube right now dude seriously
why are you not streaming fortnite right
now nick fury with uh newmaster69
what's going on
well emilia clarke's character a lot of
us are wondering that she could be
playing the squirrel varanki who is the
chief villain in the secret invasion
event in the comics she was revealed
that varenke had been uh posing as
spider-woman jessica drew for several
years now jessica drew is technically of
course a sony property so i don't know
if she could exist on this marvel disney
plush show but i do think amelia clark
could just be playing veranky
nonetheless taking some other human form
in this universe now others are
speculating that amelia clark could be
abigail brand a director of sword since
we met sword and wanavision uh and
monica rambo had those connections with
sword we're not sure if nick fury was
connected to sword because we saw him on
that squirrel space station at the end
sword could have a an off-planet
division that they cooperate with the
scrolls we just weren't really clear
where director hayward would stand on
that if he knew about that division if
it was kept secret even from him that it
was some kind of like backup nick fury
protocol deal that he had with abigail
brand but i honestly think olivia
coleman would be a really great casting
choice for evan having your brand
absolutely my that's just my head cannon
casting i like it i dig your head cannon
barrel now last week mt and i for inside
marvel checked in on marvel's mutant
plan heading into multiverse of madness
on the other side of eternals and
spider-man no way home now i want to
talk about what their scroll plan is
after we've seen all these titles so
after the recent titles from late 2021
mt who do you think is going to be most
likely revealed as a skrull imposter or
someone who might have a squirrel
duplicate the way fury and hill did and
some of the times we saw them over the
past history that we were actually
seeing their scrolls who do you think
will be revealed who do you think will
be the most shocking major player in the
mcu to be revealed as a scroll
see that's the big question man you
can't trust anybody because they can
just wreck on any anybody as a skrull i
think for me a huge shocking main player
in the mcu that could be a scroll is
general ross and well actually both
ross's um both everett ross and general
ross i think it'd be a huge like oh my
god we i mean forever ross like we
trusted you like we invited you to
wakanda and you betrayed us why how
could you do that but for general ross
would be like oh dang they're really
infiltrated because now they're leading
the military and like making decisions
and like oh my god like like this man
could potentially be president maybe but
like you know with with red hulk being
set up possibly that's not of something
that they're doing but like it would be
nuts yeah if they
i agree empty i think and i think you're
looking in the right place right in
terms of the mcu
i have a suspicion that they are not
going to reveal major already
superpowered individuals as scrolls
having already been scrolls yes they may
get swapped with scrolls as a result of
the series but uh sorcerers as guardians
you know i think there are things as uh
there are such thing as super scrolls
right where scrolls can inhabit the the
personality the characteristics and the
powers of the person they impersonate um
but i think that's like a step too far i
think it's already going to be
mind-blowing enough to have people who
we thought we knew transform into this
green screen into this green skinned
extraterrestrial so the fact that you're
looking at government employees that
otherwise don't really seem to have
superpowers but might have some like
historical irregularities we should say
um with thunderbolt ross and black widow
we're seeing more in these in these
deleted scenes from black widow that he
just kind of had this history where he
just disappeared he chalked it up to
having heart problems and having to have
triple bypass surgeries uh but the fact
that they're both where they are in the
government i think those are going to be
the kind of people who marvel reveals as
having been scrolls because that kind of
has the biggest shock value oh yeah like
sort of like winter soldier yes exactly
uh so i think yeah government employees
i think people who we have been with in
the mcu for a long time you got to have
at least one legacy mcu character who
was there since phase one or early phase
two uh and i think
it's also interesting to look at people
who have like
weirdly
technical uh insights
that
normal human beings
through our american k-12 education and
even mit instruction that they have that
was one of the things that always
weirded me out about tony stark and
howard stark
oh geez sorry
i would start was like you're talking
about me he's uh my hair isn't hurting
um
but i mean that could just chalk it up
to the to the stark uh personality the
stark intelligence and that's just there
but yeah i think it's gonna be like a
mix of government employees some people
we've been with in the mc for a long
time and then whoever the goofy side
characters are in the mcu so the ones
who make my list are the rosses right
thunderbolt and in everett ross
as well as i think hank pym is a prime
candidate oh that's a big one bro dang
he was one of the big ones at the
beginning of the secret invasion comics
it's him it's reed richards they turn on
each other hank pym has been revealed as
a scroll i don't think that would like
destabilize too many things i it might
make a quantum mania a bit weird but i
think i don't think it's awkward
yeah we already know about maria hill
and fury already had scroll duplicates
who they worked with
um
after seeing eternals what do you think
about karoon being a scroll
my heart would be broken my heart would
be shattered um i would trust no one um
literally i would have trust issues for
the rest of my life because he just he's
just so trustworthy he just like that
when he was saying goodbye to the
eternal he's like thank you so much like
this was amazing and like i was like
please like that seemed so genuine so if
he was a scroll
i would fight i would fight just but i i
just fight something my furniture um my
wall i would just be
you and i have a different
interpretation of it though because if
you were revealed as a scroll i i he's
still a very nice person and a very nice
individual and i think the way i would
see it as
that would explain why he was less
freaked out by uh
by kingo and these other eternals he
just kind of went with it walking on
board a spaceship and then he at the end
he said thank you for everything you've
done for this planet i think that's his
mission as a scroll in
in disguise he's embedded in these
places to try to do good i imagine these
versions of scrolls as like kind of like
peace corps volunteers they're on this
planet just trying to help us out and
protect us against this imperialist cree
empire the squirrels are the good guys
now i'm sure there's going to be some
bad scrolls there's going to be like
that's what's going to destabilize this
peace that we've had is there's going to
be some terrorist scrolls and all the
squirrels we know are gonna be like
they're not us that's a different group
they're crazy they sit at a different
table than us we don't know them um so
yeah i think definitely there do we
think uh either a wakandan like some
there must be someone in wakanda who is
a squirrel if they really are all over
the world
uh maybe someone in the black widow crew
like someone we saw either in the widow
organization do you think it's likelier
that one of the widow assassins could be
a scroll or one of uh the people of
wakanda i mean i think both i think that
the squirrels are everywhere and the
weddings would be a fantastic place for
the squirrels to be because you know if
a young female skrull was taken as a
child and this raised up to be a widow
it would make sense for these people to
want to spread out and infiltrate with
the infiltrators i guess with the widows
it's like that is like the ultimate
secret agents like i'm a double agent
sort of uh some sort of vibe so yeah it
would make sense for there to be uh
skrulls embedded in the widows what kind
of and like absolutely i think that like
the best thing about secret invasion is
like the feeling of
like no one is safe or like you don't
know where they they could be literally
anywhere um like cockroaches uh even
though we shouldn't call us girls
cockroaches because they're nice they're
not they're good
it's not an infestation they've been
helping us for years get out of my
planet
like i i doubt it would be like a major
wakandan player like not okoye but maybe
someone in the dora milage garden oh
yeah like like we might have a line like
we saw in uh in the falcon winter
soldier where some dora milanese show up
and they go yes we just found out three
of our guards were skrulls
it's awkward
like even like um people on the council
in wakanda like that would be nuts if
like like a person on the council was
like hey sorry
just kidding just a squirrel the entire
time now coming out of no way home uh i
was fully expected going into no way
home that they were gonna make us think
that aunt may was gonna die and then
they would kill off happy hogan but no
happy hogan was left alive and i've
always wondered like john favreau seems
like the kind of guy who would be
totally down to wear that skrull makeup
and he is one of these guys that it's
kind of like what jarvis was in the
secret invasion comics where jarvis
suddenly was revealed as a squirrel just
like you
you're here with me this whole time like
i think i would love that if they
revealed favreau as a scroll and that
would be like a high profile face it was
in a ton of the movies like that might
be
the one where it was like him
him so i've always suspected that he
might i haven't always suspected but in
recent months i've been suspecting this
maybe like that maybe aunt may figured
it out and like she walked in on her
being a scroll and she just broke up
with him he's like you know what i'm
just gonna break up with you i don't
really know what's going on but like i'm
just gonna
i'm just going be
break up with you
i like you
it's just like when we slept together
you made this weird extraterrestrial
scream like gills opened up behind your
ears and mist sprayed out i don't know
what that was about
you said something about
me i don't know what a fork is i don't
really want that and for that reason i'm
out
welcome to flirk tank
i wanted to ask you about val we never
really got answers about val other than
that she's connected it sounds like with
uh eleanor bishop perhaps kingpin
from uh from hawkeye but we don't really
know what her abilities are and i've
always suspected that she has some kind
of
connections either with the mystic arts
or with people from off world because
she knows things about the avengers
conflict that normal people even
shadowy government figures should know
about she knows about intimate
conversations that happened on vermeer
so if she's i think the idea is that she
just has some connections that people
should not have uh and
in val does have an important role
in the secret innovation event and
there's a prelude nick fury storyline
where he tracks val and realizes that
the vowel he thought he was with will
shift it back into a scroll in that
moment um i don't know if that's the
direction it seems like they could go in
like six different directions with val
still we still don't know much about her
but what do you think mt
i mean i think that val could have a
connection to the scrolls in in the way
that
she probably saw them coming um i have
this like i have this weird suspicion
that val is using the project inside
algorithm from winter soldier to sort of
oh yeah eliminate people um on the way
and i think that with that algorithm
she's just like all right squirrels are
on the board and they're probably
infiltrating i feel like val and her
people foresee the the secret invasion
thing happening and so like they're
putting their people in place it's like
all right they're not there's not gonna
be a need for captain america because
people don't trust captain america and
the avengers anymore so now we're going
to make the thunderbolts because these
are our people and they're safe and
they're verified um so i think that she
just knows that it's coming she has the
intel of the squirrels coming in the 90s
and so she's just like all right um
we're ready for the big news to break
out because people fear things of people
fear things that they don't understand
and when the people receive the
squirrels they're going to be like oh no
people all these aliens are infiltrating
our planet and so we have to fight
against them and so they're sort of
orchestrating this like um you know this
push back this narrative against the
squirrels um on a world stage
that'd be interesting that val might use
this secret invasion to
stir even more
misinformation out there and to play her
levers of power in a way that like turn
people against each other she releases
like a fake dossiers out there or fake
propaganda that says such and such might
be a squirrel but they're not or she
might uh kind of like you know during
the mccarthy hearings out people for
being scrolls and hold these big trials
or something like that you know or
except someone else to hold your house
she just like uses sharpie to draw like
a weird chin on on a hulk and he's like
oh look how to scroll
i knew it
um now i'm kind of looking at the secret
invasion cast and wondering who among
them or what other mcu character might
be that kind of government blow hard and
christopher mcdonald's going to be in
the show aka shooter mcgavin this guy's
such a great character actor he was in
hacks on hbo on hbo max um he's such a
fantastic actor i wonder if he might be
playing like a government figure like a
senator who's like i have a list of
known scrolls of the government
and we'll get to the bottom of all of
them
uh like i found this on geocities
hold on it's stopped matrix burner so i
gotta just tear off the perforated sides
okay
one moment oh it tore into paper
but this guy's great i mean this cast
guys i just can't get over how much i
love everyone in this cast it's not just
like oh they cast that one action actor
who did stunts in that movie i'm making
i'm not saying that i'm hating on
all-star i think most stunt actors
usually surprise you with how good of
actors they are um
but i'm just saying like these are all
actors that look like either been part
of the oscars conversation or have won
oscars before and that's exciting
usually just have one of those in these
shows so the fact that we have so many
it's like
he's so excited
um emmy the question we we want to ask
why does nick fury no longer wear his
eye patch on this show or why does he no
longer shave why is he doing this um
thor ragnarok odin deleted scene look
that he seems to be having we are
definitely going to talk about that but
first we want to thank our friends at
peloton for sponsoring this episode
you'd get bored watching the same thing
on tv every day you'd get just as bored
doing the same workout over and over
again right well peloton is adding a ton
of new and exciting classes to their app
to keep you motivated to work out
peloton has a workout for every goal
every day every mood de-stress from a
long day with 30 minutes of strength 20
minutes of cardio or do a quick
15-minute total body class before work
stay motivated while having fun with
bike workouts yoga meditation dance
cardio and more they even have some cool
new boxing classes peloton is adding fun
new artist series classes as well work
out to the music of a single artist for
an entire class from pop and rock to hip
hop to edm there are over 100 artists
series to choose from and for a limited
time try the peloton app free for two
months then 12.99 a month after that new
members only visit onepeleton.com app to
learn more that's two months free at
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com offer expires
january 31 2022 terms apply we also want
to thank our friends at stance socks for
sponsoring this episode i've got some
stamp socks in my sock drawer or in one
of my socks boxes socks box
always happy to put these on my feet
they feel so great we know they make the
best socks in the biz and now they're
bringing color comfort and creativity
from toe to head with the launch of
their all new active apparel line stance
has a super soft line of sweatpants and
joggers shirts and hoodies and more that
are stylish enough to wear out and about
they're available in a full range of
fits prints and fabrics i think the
coolest part of stance apparel is all
their collaborations you can wear your
nightmare before christmas hoodie or
your wu-tang clan sweatpants or darth
vader socks mix it all up it's awesome
stance's philosophy is that you should
never have to sacrifice your own
individual style for the sake of comfort
and now you don't have to whether you're
relaxing around the house working out at
the gym or running all over town stance
now delivers its signature softness and
creativity and a full line of active
apparel styles from toe to head stance
has got you covered head on over to
stance.com and get 15 off your first
purchase use promo code marvel at
checkout to apply enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance stitched different all right mt i
wanted to ask you the question why the
flirkin does nick fury no longer wear
his eye patch and secret invasion do you
think that's the big question man
because
every time we've seen nick fury he's
usually wearing his eye patch unless
it's the end of you know the winter
soldier and he's rocking the sunglasses
look um but i think that you know given
that secret invasion is going to be
dealing with a lot of scrolls and you
know a lot of like evil scroll or like
or antagonist scrolls to nick fury i
honestly think that this could be a
power move it's like hey check this out
flurkin scratch my eyeball you don't
want to mess with me bro all right i
have a wound from a dangerous creature
and since the scrolls fear the flirkins
they're like oh my god like this kid
this guy's for real like he survived he
probably killed the flerkin with his
bare hands how did he do that he's
legitimate um so i think you could be
like a scare tactic honestly um just
because he's just a normal man dealing
with all these like you know super human
institution extraterrestrial um you know
technologies and in entities so like he
has to have a one-up he has to scare
um these people that don't know that
nick fury is the one to be feared um so
i think that could be a reason there uh
but it also could be talos because like
just implying that like i i can see
through my eye my eyes this is just a
little disguise i think um i think
you're on to a couple of good things
there first off yeah this is a new era
of nick fury he's not the avengers era
of nick fury anymore he's a nick fury
who might be trying to either scare
people or win over the public though i
think he looks scarier now than he did
of before um
but yeah i'm wondering if he has a
squirrel now we know scrolls can
impersonate clothes right that's a
simple enough thing they can shapeshift
their molecular structure around to just
wear whatever you're wearing and that
includes an eye patch but i wonder if
now nick fury
this could be like a little plot point
that he he has a new eye patch designed
by the good scrolls or whoever his tech
savvy friends are so that it cannot be
duplicated and that's how you know
there's the only nick fury he has this
one particular eye patch that is
impossible to be duplicated uh but not
everyone in the world knows that yet so
you have another squirrel who's back on
earth
who is uh who is impersonating him as
like a crazy uh uh rambling conspiracy
theorist who never shaves and lives up
in the woods and screaming things and
he's like you thought i was dead but i'm
not i'm still alive and the world is
filled with squirrels and then so they
the bad scrolls i mean still imagining
two different camps of scrolls good ones
and bad ones the bad ones might have
like kidnapped him or something that but
they can't extract his his eye patch or
they can't remove it and they're pissed
off about that so they just sent another
one to impersonate him as an insane
lunatic
and that just sews information so no one
knows who to trust at that point so this
version of fury that we see who's
bearded without the eye patch is a
squirrel impersonator but not the good
kind that talos
okay just like an evil that's my theory
that would be pretty i would love to see
just an antagonistic or like or just
like a crazier version of nick fury in
general just like something just just to
see like samuel jackson just like just
give us like subvert expectations for
what we know nick fury to be like just
through a scroll a scroll um performance
yeah i think that's that might be a
reason why they're getting so many great
actors in the show is at some point even
if they're human they're gonna get
impersonated by a scroll and they're
gonna need to play those different
identities which is one of the fun
things that you know i think was
unappreciated from captain marvel how
often characters were revealed to be
scrolls and then those actors got to be
a little shady for a few scenes clark
gregg right didn't he yeah he was a
person who very scroll and got to have a
bit of fun with that i thought that was
great you tried to murder nick fury
a little question that we never got
answered coming out of loki uh what was
the violation of that variant scroll
that we saw in the tva check-in desk in
the loki episode one well isn't there
like a an unaccounted for scroll from
captain marvel um there is there's a
fourth scroll what are we never caught
up with
what if that's like the mcu's way of
just being like oh we got him
there he is pleased
we got him
like it was like a mistake on marvel
studios like oh whoops we forgot the
scroll it's like oh we don't worry about
it we picked him up that would be
hilarious i would love that but he is
wearing like a tracksuit isn't he like a
little track
type deal so maybe yes yes maybe he's
part of the dragon i don't know
maybe
maybe i think the reason i i find this
question interesting is the reason he's
in that lobby is whatever he did was
considered a violation in the eyes of
the tva so some scroll
stepped in the wrong part of the
timeline and so that would be marvel's
suggestion if this was that fourth
scroll who got away that this girl's
escape or something else he did later in
his life was considered off the script
of the sacred timeline in some
interesting way like we don't know how
much of the tva's logic to trust because
we had what miss minutes told us we had
what other characters told us and then
we had what kang or the kang variant
told us at the end so we don't know if
it was just like
they did something consciously or
unconsciously or if like loki was
targeted more than your average variant
was we don't know how much of that was
true by the end of it and i think that
ultimately characters who were detained
were ones who like
really
went out of step with what seemed to be
faded for themselves that they made some
crazy choice it wasn't just like oh i
decided to get a skinny latte today i
think they had to have done something
pretty dastardly everyone there seemed
to be like now the counter argument
there would be sylvie right sylvia was
just playing with her toys we don't know
what she did before she's playing with
those toys maybe she pushed a man off a
ledge and said i'm going to be
give me them toys
give me those toys
no was it just playing with toys was it
her very existence i think that was the
implication right by the end sophie was
like i didn't do anything just my very
existence was considered
uh
expungable from reality from all of
realities uh so i think this girl i
would love if like there was something
in particular he did like maybe this was
like the assassin scroll that started a
huge conflict between the cree and the
squirrel even though that was ancient
he's wearing a tracksuit now um maybe
this was one who uh like threw a molotov
cocktail right if he was a tracksuit guy
but that one sparked a war to where the
united states government became aware of
the existence of scrolls so the tva is
trying to
trying to
just prune him
so the secret so there's no knowledge of
the secret invasion on earth because
that's too destabilizing of the status
quo that'd be interesting i like that
actually the last question i want to ask
you as we wrap up our scroll
conversation amt that one division
post-credits scene uh we all got
overwhelmed by that second post-credit
scene of wanda with the dark hole of
course but there was that first film
with a freaking scroll recruiting monica
rambo to go visit someone up in the sky
now we assume that was nick fury but
could it have been someone else could it
have been her squirrel leader played by
kingsley benadir
maybe maybe i think
that you know it could be in reference
to any because like nick fury's
obviously not the only squirrel that
monica um came or a person of interest
that monica came into contact with
during the events of captain marvel um i
think kingsley ben adir could actually
be playing nick fury's son who is
revealed as a squirrel and nick fury's
like where's my son why'd you take my
son
so you say nick fury had a relationship
with with a squirrel posing as a human
and that their their child was this girl
maybe or possibly that his son was taken
by the squirrels and was replaced by a
scroll imposter to try to get to nick
fury to try to you know kill him to you
know obviously an evil scroll not a good
scroll um to try to kill nick fury
because he's trying to advance an agenda
that they don't really care about um so
i i think that he might be playing that
in particular but i think in terms of
the
um that that link you know there there
is also taylor's daughter like there's
this huge i feel like there's this
teaser in captain marvel one that kind
of leaves taylor's daughter with like oh
is violence okay i just saw my dad kill
somebody i'm in the name of violence um
so i think that maybe it could be
taylor's daughter it's like hey come on
up um i miss you buddy buddy o'pal
because they would probably be the same
age
see what i think is daughter is going to
be varanke and that like taylor is like
look i lost touch with my daughter she's
out of control i can't talk to her okay
they're like you have to talk to her
it's gonna she's gonna destroy the
status quo piece so it's going to make
it personal right she splits away from
her dad and utilis represents the older
generation of just like cold war peace
you know give piece of chance squirrels
cooperation's better than war and she's
like no screw that it hasn't done
anything for us we're still refugees
helping out these humans for no reason
let's blow it all up and burn it down
and that's going to be i think that's
going to be amelia clark as varenke and
he's like oh i can't talk to her she's
just out of control she's she's flown
off the handle have you had tried having
a daughter she's out of control of
different children bro that's pretty
damning that's a great ben mendelsohn
bro
scroll uh ben scrolderson i just made it
but i think that's where things are
ahead i think you're right i think that
daughter is going to come back that
little moment in captain marvel i think
was uh the first start of like she
looked at that cree getting shot and
she's like why don't we do this to
everyone like i think her plane uno and
she's that's just like a clue she's like
huh i'm going to what's it called where
you reverse it like she's reversing this
[ __ ] she's playing the reverse
reverse she's going to burn it down
and i love the idea of her being like
taylor's daughter i love the idea of
nick fury having a family i think that's
great like kind of like this men in
black tommy lee jones character kind of
thing he had a relationship with one of
these aliens he met and he loves her and
it's beautiful um but that is it for
this episode of inside marvel obviously
we're going to be talking about secret
invasion a lot more in the months ahead
but don't forget to check out our many
great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me at eavos
follow mt mastertainment subscribe to
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcasts thank you for watching and we
know which of you are squirrels but we
won't help you
we have a list
we printed it out we checked it twice
all right goodbye we love you bye
you